this podcast and every other podcast
that i make is brought to you by the
supporters on patreon not only are they
the reason that a very niche show like
this one can exist which will never
cover its own cost because it's nowhere
near popular enough but they also get
extra content they get ad-free versions
of shows unedited versions of podcasts
outtakes and bloopers from other content
and more of course depending on the tier
huge thank you to everyone who supports
on patreon and if you've ever considered
doing so because you like these shows
you find them informative or helpful in
any way go to patreon.com
even one dollar helps hello everyone
welcome to another episode of video game
writing 101 i'm alana that's georgia and
that's jason who are co-writers of
wayward strand
which is just about to come out of the
day this publishes is going up on monday
yeah so a couple of days away
yeah um ah that's scary
yeah how are you feeling
uh yeah it's it's it's a wild ride yeah
because we've been making this game for
like close to seven years wow
yeah for most of that time it hasn't
been just about to come out so
to adjust to why uh why is such a long
development cycle
um
like i think part of it has been um
that like
uh that it is kind of a bit of an
experimental game and it took us a while
to like kind of
narrow down to like exactly what we
wanted to do like we had all these like
really big ideas and kind of
had to scrap some of them and and then
or kind of found some that were like
really cool so we were like all right
we've kind of got to
remake it but now we know
more of what we're trying to do yeah and
then the other part has just been
funding uh
that's a
situation of its own
yeah um so for anyone who doesn't know
what wayward strand is the as soon as i
saw this and i saw it was australian and
i to me it looked very creative
narratively but you guys will do a much
better job of explaining it um what
exactly is it how would you describe
what it is as a narrative experience
um i can do the the spiel that we're all
very good here now
um
so word strand is a narrative game where
you play as casey who's a 14 year old
girl and her mother is the head nurse on
the local hospital airship um the game
set in 1970s in regional victoria and
it's set over three days in school
holidays where you go with your mum to
her place of work the hospital and your
role there is just to spend time with
the people on the aged care ward and
keep them company and
yeah find out about their stories and
and their lives
i have to say this game made me feel
like
like maybe homesick more than anything
else i've ever played because a lot of
the old people are so rude
and i was like that's my grandma
that's amazing she's just about to turn
95 and she's so blunt and i was like and
that australian accent she's victorian
lives in victoria and i was like damn
it's just like i'm home being roasted by
an old woman again
i think a lot of people's very first
impression is that it's really cozy and
cute and i think it is really cozy and
cute but it was really important to us
to not have these sort of cardboard cut
out like lovely grandma
who's gonna like just offer ut and be
nice to you like for every character
like there is at least one character who
is like that who's just genuinely lovely
um but yeah a huge part of what
motivates us in making this game is that
um all the
are their own whole people with their
own rich inner lives and um they've had
experiences and they've had some
difficult experiences and some of them
are lovely and some of them are less
lovely and they're just like people of
any other age um with all their
different uh foibles and characteristics
they are all very different and also
very memorable and i feel like that's
something that's
very well conveyed in the game a very
small space of time is it very quickly
you learn this is this person this is
how i identify them this is where their
room is or where they are physically and
i feel like i was very very impressed by
that and one thing that i know about
this game but i've only gotten through
one playthrough so i'm excited to
continue to play through it and see how
it changes
so you have a little clock in your
bottom right corner and it's
close to real time
um
yeah it's it's multiplied by i think
it's like a factor of eight
but um yeah yeah to get through those
three days right yeah yeah totally
people will potentially be in different
places at different times so you know
the first thing that i did in my first
playthrough was try to find the woman
who was telling me about the goat which
i was like who was that i want to figure
out more about what's going on there and
then maybe the second time i won't do
that i'll follow like where the headless
tells me to go or i'll follow a
different lead so i'm correct in
assuming that every time you play
through this
it's not a choice-based situation where
it's going to be like at this path this
path it is more of an open space where
the narrative will unfold differently
depending on where you are at what time
correct
yeah
yeah and i think something that's unique
about our game and which also played
into why it took such a dang long time
to make is that um our npcs don't just
wait for you to approach there they've
got stuff to do um they are living their
lives and uh so if you come past
someone's room and they're in the middle
of a visit from a nurse or a doctor or
they're having a meal then that's what
they're in the middle of doing um and
you have to if you want to talk to them
you have to wait for them to be done
with what they're doing
um to interact with them so
even if you choose to speak to the same
character first if you get there faster
or slower it'll
influence
what you see so how on earth did you
guys approach writing for that like is
there or was there a main through line
that that you expected people to follow
like literally what does your like jira
look like like how do you plan
um if there's this many people doing
this many different things it can be
completely missed how do you prioritize
what you're writing
yeah i mean it was just a massive
massive challenge like it was uh i think
um
the way
like the way that i described that we
ended up doing it was really in like a
whole bunch of passes so we kind of like
you know plan like plot out the whole
game uh with like just a few of the
scenes written kind of plan it out and
then do that again uh like as we found
like inconsistencies or things that
don't fit together then do it again
and then we like wrote like a whole heap
of it um
and then we kind of just i yeah i guess
just kept doing passes through it to
like every pass that we do like um
inconsistencies would kind of fall away
or we'd like yeah figure out that ah
because this person talks to this person
at this time then they really need to
mention that to this other person and
that can flow out into a different
storyline and
um yeah
it was it was kind of a lot
yeah
is there a yeah go ahead georgia
i think there's an element of surrender
to it as well like i think that
in a more conventional video game you
perhaps or a more conventional narrative
video game you perhaps know that there's
like a lot of stuff that you that it's
really critical for the player to find
out or even maybe find out in the
correct sequence whereas for us
um we're really invested in building
this very rich world and we know that if
a player on any given playthrough
doesn't find out this or that or the
other or you know 90 of the stuff we
know that the world has still been
enriched by that stuff being there and
if someone chooses to replay it they'll
find different things um but there's
there's a huge amount of narrative
content but there's actually a very
small amount of narrative content that's
essential for the player to find out to
make sense of things or have a good time
so how do you pick like a or was there a
path a like did you have a
kind of a road map for what exactly
those essential things were and how to
dish out that information
um well like we basically
have uh uh yeah one thing that we did
decide on fairly early is that there is
basically a critical narrative path
between casey and her mom ruth who's
like the head nurse of the hospital and
those are the like um those mainly play
out during kind of the bookends that are
at the start and end of each day
um
and then there are definitely
things that tie into that storyline that
happen throughout the game
uh that where we where we don't know
where the player is going to be but
we're kind of like
um basically you could be hanging out
with any one of these seven different
characters and if you're hanging out
with them you're going to have a scene
with them that relates to that main arc
um but
that isn't required for you to see that
scene in order for the main arc to make
sense yeah um so
yeah that was kind of our like
concession to like
all right if we really have it just be
100 open
then there's a possibility that a player
just has no
nothing to like
anchor themselves to or like in terms of
like the narrative
um
but yeah other than that it is really
like we we almost
actively pushed against the thought of
like
maybe this is like the main like a
primary path for a player through the
game like there's a little bit of stuff
i guess on the first day where
you get told to go to a particular
patient's room and wait we kind of
assume like oh yeah maybe most players
will do that on their first playthrough
but um
but other than that we just tried to
make everything as kind of compelling
and put as much time into it as as
everything else
i feel like it must have been really
hard to do like yeah
it's like you have to have
just sort of let yourself ignore a lot
of game writing conventions which i
think is what's so cool about this game
and i actually get a lot of studios
would love to do it but it's really
scary
yeah yeah there's like
not knowing where anyone is going to be
at any point in time makes delivering an
impactful narrative a very difficult
thing to do because you can't have those
um you know like the songbird moments of
fire shock and fear where you're like i
know where you're gonna be and how
you're gonna feel when this happens and
i don't know what's the lack of control
feel like
like is it something you ever stressed
about or was it just something that you
let yourselves just be engulfed in
i think again it's just that thing where
we have so many different like threads
to the narrative that it didn't it there
were other things about writing it that
felt stressful but the idea that um
people we wouldn't know where people
were going or what they would be
experiencing out of the available
options was actually probably exciting
rather than stressful and maybe um
something that helps with you know this
going against every rule in the game
writing playbook is that i'm not a game
writer so i've never read that playbook
that's good that i think that helps
sometimes yeah so i have a different
perspective
yeah i come from theater and um
it is very theater
yeah okay great um yeah the whole team
had been really inspired by immersive
theater shows which also have this
convention which fans of immersive
theater love and people who get dragged
along to immersive theater by their
age which is that you don't get to see
the whole thing um it's like kind of the
selling point but also the weakness but
you know if it's what you like then you
love it um and so that's already what
i'm accustomed to is like a what we
would call in theater a dramaturgy of um
of yeah of knowing how to
like how to enrich
player experience or audience experience
wherever they are rather than needing to
do so in a linear way
i imagine when reviews go up you are
going to get a lot of uh sleep no more
comparisons which is a thing that like
you know it comes up in the show all the
time when i talk to other studios about
what they want to make people bring it
up a lot and again i'm just like so
impressed that you guys did it what was
the the uh
biggest difference between what you were
working on seven years ago and what's
coming out in at the time of publishing
two days like what was the biggest
change
oh there used to be a cat
oh yeah that's right you caught that
yeah
so much is different i feel like maybe
jason you've got a bit more of an
encyclopedic memory of what in
particular was different was there like
was the pitch different to start with um
like uh
we've actually got versions of the game
from back then and um like one of the
big changes was how it's gone from like
previously we it was in full in full 3d
and it was almost shot like a like a tv
show or that kind of thing so like you'd
go to a room and like the cameras would
be jumping around and like as it was
like falls i think that's the name of
that game if you saw that um
yeah
they actually did uh
night and it is a game that they
actually did shoot like it was a set
but then like put art so
i'm explaining really badly if you see
it it might that might be similar yeah
you're talking about yeah totally and
actually at that time i i was like
getting into because like
vr stuff was like getting bigger and i
was like oh what if we like
shot every scene like kind of physically
like um like i'd have you know a um
like a vive controller and i'd be like
in the scene like directing the camera
like as it's going and that like i was
super into that and spent months on the
programming of that and uh
then we kind of made an initial demo and
we were like
we made seven scenes and it took us like
two years
so if we need to have like a thousand
scenes or however many that we're at
around about that in the final game
we're gonna need to um simplify this a
little bit so
so that's kind of where the change to
sight on came in and kind of i think
that like kind of
um
like
like dollhouse vibe uh like like it was
at least very dope house yeah yeah yeah
it was like a visual change but also
just actually um had such a big
influence on like
just the structure of the game and the
way that it the way that it works and
everything like i'd say that's one of
the biggest the biggest changes i guess
when you first start out you don't
really know how anything's gonna look
especially if it's a writing first
studio that could be really hard you
have to change a lot of stuff to sort of
make that uh cohesive vision work it's
complicated yeah
um you kind of touched on it before
georgia but uh
you said you know that not knowing my
players would be was not stressful but
other aspects were what was the most
challenging thing about writing this
game uh i think jason and i would
probably have very different answers to
this based on our different roles
because my role was um
you know co-writing with jason and then
voice over direction and jason was
co-writing and then much more on the
production and technical
actually just on the everything so
jason did the writing and the everything
from writing and the voiceover um but
for me and this again alludes to you
know my history not being in video games
um even though i'm used to having like
split narratives where you know audience
members can go off and try different
things
when you're a theater maker
um or even like in prose which i also
write um your role as the writer is to
decide the one set of things that happen
so for me the most challenging thing in
writing this game is to come up with
enough dialogue options to give the
player a sense that they were in this
world
without just
making it free reign anyone can say
whatever the hell they want um and i
think that we are
you know i think in any kind of first
player first person narrative game not
that it's like inside first person but
any narrative game where you sort of you
have the player character
um there's like the aperture of how much
choice the player has to influence the
character that they're playing like i'm
just thinking about this at the moment
because i'm
finally playing disco elysium and the
aperture is incredibly wide like you can
jump game you can beat anyone as that
character like you can be like a
communist or a fascist you can be like a
total misanthrope or you can be very
hopeful or you can be like a feminist or
you can be like a real sleazebag like
it's just totally up to you whereas
casey's aperture is
quite a bit narrower like there are
there's different versions of casey and
we kind of talk about like
one of the people in our team tom
anytime you play test the game he just
like plays the
rudest bratty
version of casey that is available so
there's i kept going with all the
journalist options i was always like i'm
a journalist i'm here to write an
article and i did that every single time
because i was like as a 14 year old
that's what i was doing but i was like
the next time i play i'm excited to not
mention any of that and see what happens
and i imagine it can't change her as a
character fundamentally and i liked her
i feel like she's a very likable
character to follow through but it is
exciting that that's a thing you can
explore or completely not explore
yeah
but even with that narrower aperture
than some other narrative games it was
still challenging to know like how to
how to carve multiple paths through the
same scene which all felt equally
authoritative so that whichever one of
those cards that you end up on as a
player it makes sense with what you know
about yourself and about the characters
around you are there challenges where
voice directing is concerned with that
as well like i've done a tiny bit of
writing on an nda thing where it was
choice-based but everything funneled
eventually back into
one answer and even writing it myself
and reading back what i would do is like
read every single possible outcome so
that um i would make sure that the jump
from one to another one didn't make the
character sound nuts and i feel like
that must be very hard to direct actors
to do because you have to make sure
every
part of the tree
still has the same tone because what if
they say something rude and then they
say something polite and i feel like
like loads of games suffer um
aaa has a really tough time with that in
a way that i did not think wavewood
strand did i didn't feel like anyone was
like oh you were weirdly mad there and
then you weren't uh is that a tough
thing to approach when it comes to
directing actors is that something you
have to think about a lot
yes
it is
um we um
we i think we probably didn't anticipate
how challenging um i think once we were
thinking about it we came up with some
really good processes which i'll speak
to but um right before we started the
voiceover recording we started looking
at oh okay how do we actually like
process these scripts for and the other
thing is our cast were
fairly exclusively people who haven't
done video game voice over and or maybe
haven't done voiceover we've got some
people who've done voiceover but mostly
they had experience in either theater or
in television and film um so very much
accustomed to like my character has one
thing that they say per
second you know
um cannot be saying multiple things or
feeling multiple things you know
depending on someone else's actions um
and we initially thought we would just
print out every every scene and just get
them to read it start to finish but as
you've identified alana it's like how am
i going to say
i don't mind and then also say i don't
want to do that like at like one after
the other so we ended up what we ended
up doing per scene is that we
traced a path through the scene we had
the lines of dialogue numbered and then
we traced the path through the scene
with the numbered lines saying this is
one entire version of the scene and got
the actors to record that entire version
first that was like emotionally
coherent it made sense and then we'd say
all right we're now going to jump back
up and get line three which we skipped
over which contradicts line two and just
get that in isolation um and we with all
of the actors we started in that way and
some of them we continued in that way
throughout their whole recording and
others got the gist of what that meant
earlier on and just sort of preferred to
go start to finish and were able to just
sort of like chameleonically just change
in and out of emotions per line once
they understood how the script was
formatted i feel like that must be hard
for actors to like to keep an idea of
who your character is and what their arc
is it's got to be a tough challenge for
them as well
just so many challenges that this
presents
yeah yeah we decided to really put life
on hard mode with them
yeah
like
uh i reckon with the vr process it was
definitely handy like because georgia
and i would be at most sessions and kind
of like georgia was doing the actual
theory direction and like working with
the actors to get the performances and
stuff but then like you know uh myself
and also like maze who
um
did the like vo tech stuff uh was it
most of the sessions as well and
i think having a few of us there kind of
listening out for like
oh maybe we need to take that line a
little bit less aggressively so that it
will flow better into
that the other line like that might
happen was that is that editing process
really difficult too then like how do
you
track
i don't even know how to phrase the
question i'm trying to ask i just i just
feel like when you have that many
options and again you're still trying to
make sure your characters are cohesive
which is very clearly an important part
of this game um and could be especially
complicated with elderly people when
some of them do have memory issues if
you accidentally made it seem like they
all did by having you know disconnected
uh uh tones or emotions and dialogue i
feel like that could really mess things
up is that a really like lengthy editing
process or is more of that workload in
the vo booth
there's workload in both places for sure
um so there was a lot of pre-work for
maze our audio director um
and they had these enormous pro tools
files per scene with one marker per line
of dialogue
and then each scene is in a different
pro tools file and then maze worked with
their team to um slice it up so that
every single numbered line of dialogue
was its own little audio file um
and so yeah you know that's that's only
the tip of the iceberg of like how that
was then transformed into the smooth
flying thing that you hear in the game
um but yeah it had to be taken very
piece by piece
in order to yeah flow
the way that seven years is making sense
now
well that part all happened this year
really
yeah
wow that doesn't have a lot of work yeah
vo in like yeah february march also
so i'm going to ask you jason the same
question i asked george what was the
most challenging thing about working on
this view
yeah definitely the editing was yeah was
was was challenging just trying to make
sure that everything kind of fit
together and i think that's that's kind
of where like like we've like we've had
a playable version of the game for a
long time um
and we're like we just kind of like play
it and we're like oh yeah you know this
doesn't really fit with this so we'll
have to like take that out or change it
like
um
but yeah that um
i think uh i think on the editing side
because i do
come from like a programming background
so i kind of had a bit more of the um
like i was able to apply a bit more of
that in real time
yeah yeah
yeah exactly like having a bit more of
that like fitting together all of these
kind of yeah logical blocks or whatever
was was was handy um but then obviously
yeah i didn't really have like a writing
uh you know much writing experience at
the start of this so georgia and i i
think just make a really good team from
that perspective
i was going to ask like where the
characters are concerned uh are any of
them pulled from your actual
grandparents
it would be tempting to do that
no
we're as the team everyone in the team
has really deep connections to various
different characters
awesome
yeah it'd be it'd be hard not to i think
like when you have that that soft spot
for
the elderly obviously who are often not
represented in video games so it's kind
of nice to see too
um
sorry uh uh yeah i was just gonna
quickly say like i think um that that
kind of ties into a thing that has been
really cool on this game as well which
is that like
the storylines of the characters and
like who they are and all of that stuff
like we really you know me and georgia
obviously had a lot of um input on that
and kind of uh did did the actual like
scene dialogue writing but we developed
a lot of that as a team um so like
they're kind of like five or six of us
on the core team would kind of sit down
with like butcher's paper and kind of
like
go through each character's basically
day
um or three days and map it out and
figure out what their emotional state is
and
um like so i think the characters really
feel
yeah not only very influenced by me and
georgia but also by the rest of the team
which is really cool how big was the
team
um
yeah there's like yeah there's kind of
like yeah six ish also of us on like the
core team uh but then
because there's so many different bits
that go into this game like animation
and
um yeah like all the different like uh
sound effects for the characters
movements and and all the all the
different little bits that need to go
into a 3d
um fully voiced game i think we've
probably got around 30 or so
um collaborators that have like come on
to the game at various moments um
you know sometimes for just a few weeks
to like make a particular
like set of props or something or you
know um and then other people being on
for like a couple of years doing doing
uh
yeah animations or whatever i did love
that you had the credits
very early and also that it just says
developed by you see a little bit more
of that more often i think it's a really
good thing to do
yeah it's i mean i assume that that
includes for people who only worked on
the game for a couple of weeks right
like that yeah like that's it's just
seems so much nicer than making people
have to like grovel for a credit which
is just such a gross weird thing the
industry does like and again having them
first i was like that's a really nice
touch too
yeah that's awesome yeah like yeah i
think it's a bit of a team philosophy
thing that we just
um
you know we don't really see it as oh
you know you worked in this game the
whole time therefore you had like the
big that like a gigantic impact on what
it is and everybody else didn't like
it's very much um
you know somebody might have come in and
just done that a couple of weeks but the
game is like i think fundamentally
different because of their like
contribution and um
you know it couldn't exist without them
basically it's a very good idea um
so what do you both hope that people
when they can play like
it'd be great if you have different
answers but i'm not gonna force you to
do that uh what do you hope people take
from it
um
i
hope
that
gosh we've spoken about this so much and
now that it's like so close i'm like wow
i'm just like like your perspective
changes when it's the week it's
happening
yeah it's real crazy it's like
it's i've been able i think i've been
able to answer this question really
confidently in the past because i'm like
release that'll happen eventually
but now people are really going to play
it next week um yeah in like under a
week i hope
i mean something that i see in this game
is um a moment in time
in casey's life which i think is a
moment that happens to everyone at a
very different age but that does happen
to everyone which is the moment where
you
realize that um you know and for some
people this happens very very young for
some people it has to happen very young
some people haven't so much later
realizing that the adults in your life
aren't about you
um and don't like exist for your benefit
um
i have some friends here in melbourne
who do
like this arts project where they um
get kids to dress their parents up for a
portrait and then they take the photo
but in doing the dressing up for the
portrait the artists ask the kids and
it's targeted very narrowly at sort of
like 10 to 12 year olds i think or maybe
eight to 10 year olds um they ask them
things about their parents like what
does your
dad like doing and kids will say some
stuff like dad likes picking me up from
school
um
or whatever and then it's like what is
your dad like doing when you're not
around and it's like the first time
this kid has like considered ah
when i'm not around that's such an
interesting project that's cool
yeah but i think our game in a very
different way is sort of like it's like
the next level of recognition of that of
like being
around older people
and
seeing just how
rich their inner lives are
um and yes i suppose it's a very
long-winded way of saying i hope that it
inspires curiosity in people
about um particularly older folks but
also just like the adults in their lives
generally especially for our younger
players but really for people of any age
like i think the characters that are in
our game
whether whether it's because they're
older whether it's because they're
hospital staff they're the kinds of
people that you typically kind of see
for their function before you see for
themselves um and i hope that it
inspires curiosity and people to sort of
like go into their own life and be like
oh i wonder what
my grandma's doing right now well i'm
not around you know that's a very
interesting answer i've been you know
interviewing devs for
10 12 years now and i've never had
anybody say anything like that before
like usually it's you know hope they
connect with it or they think about
their mental health but the idea of uh
wanting people to reflect upon other
people more as humans is a very very
interesting answer and you're right that
i think it can it can do that and that i
have this habit of looking at my
grandma's she's old she's gonna ask me
the same question 10 times and then i
never like sat down and asked her what
her childhood is like or whatever you
know until last year where i was like
what was it like growing up when you
were poor and you couldn't afford a
potato like i hadn't even
thought about it it was a very
interesting answer and uh yeah you
you could make people connect with their
families very well if that yeah if
that's what goes down how about you
jason what's your answer there yeah i
mean definitely
yeah definitely what what georgia was
speaking about is like a big thing for
me um i think like there's there's also
a very particular kind of element to the
game which is about like
um because you can play it multiple
times and kind of follow different
characters into
um like into a particular scene like you
can kind of follow you know one
character into a scene one time you play
and then the other time you're spending
time with another character and follow
them into that same scene
i think yeah kind of like um an
extension of that is thinking about how
i guess like how people interact with
each other and how people
kind of have
their
perspective and view on things and and
people might like have an argument or
have a disagreement or whatever or just
like bounce off each other in a really
weird way
and um if you are only able to see one
perspective of that you'd be like oh
that other person is just a jerk or
whatever but like
in wayward strand you can actually
follow both people into that and it and
i think it makes any interaction like
that feel
complex and interesting and kind of like
you can understand both perspectives
depending on who you followed into it
and um
yeah i'm really excited for people to
like find that stuff and kind of realize
like
i guess i guess it feels like that's the
thing that we gain like when we lose in
storytelling
techniques like the ability to like
control the player's path through the
game we kind of gain this ability for
the player to like
find
find these moments where they can
discover for themselves like um yeah
these like interesting things about
perspective or whatever definitely yeah
and it can make you introspective in a
lot of ways and that's definitely a
thing that i consider to usually be a
strength of video games as a medium it's
because you're really you know you're
you're actively causing the story to
happen especially in a game like wayward
strand i think it can make us a lot more
empathetic a lot more introverted once
once we leave
um introverted it's not the right word
but i'm forgetting the one that i want
to introspective there
when you like leave that experience um
which leads me into a question that i
love asking people
what do you think i'm gonna phrase it
this way for this particular game what
do you think that games can learn from
theater and vice versa what do you think
theater can learn from video games
it's a tough one
i think something this is it's
part of why this is tough is that
theater is huge and video games is huge
like there are so many
different ways there's different
audiences in a lot of cases you know
yeah but even within video games and
even within theater such different
audiences because i
i've been thinking recently about how um
video games like wayward strand but a
lot of other video games as well
seem to be interested especially
recently i think some recent releases
are interested in bringing us inside the
perspective of someone who
you would have a difficult find the time
finding them showcased in some other
media like in in a play or in a tv show
or whatever um and it seems seems like
there are some
video games and some game studios and
game makers at the moment that are
interested in like narrative games that
are about marginal perspectives
um
and
i think the theater would do well to do
that but i don't know if that's
something that is a characteristic of
video games i think it's a an affordance
of video games i think video games can
do that very effectively um
but
yeah i think
you think it could be more challenging
to to share those kind of perspectives
through theater
uh no if anything i think less
challenging because um you know for
whatever marginal perspective that
you're um
putting forward you can have like bodies
in the space um and you can have someone
who has that lived experience who is on
stage who is um you know sharing of
their own experience and communing with
audience in real time
um
i think what i can i can say actually
one thing that i feel pretty confidently
that games can learn from theater which
is like um uh
writing that's good
i i yeah i
hope that our writing is good and i
aspire to that and um you know i don't
want to shoot our own horn too much
that's for the audience to decide but um
so many video games that are so
interesting in so many other ways seem
to have this
still this very like schlocky kind of
approach to dialogue in particular um
which feels unnecessary it sort of feels
like the time for that is over and
you've got like you know all the voice
over talent in the world and all the
writing talent in the world out there
and i'm sure that any given playwright
or screenwriter would beat down the door
of any video games company if given the
chance
um so just like
yeah writing that's good i think the
problem is just a lot of those video
game companies go
and we can figure out the writing later
we're trying to get the the combat or
the level design and and that's where
the problem lies is like the amount of
people
in the way that different studios
prioritize that stuff it is a problem
and
like video game writing in a lot of
cases is very generic and bland and
sometimes not even written by writers uh
it's it's just written by you know
whoever had to do the level design for
that particular level and i really also
hope it changes like a lot of it's just
so generic in a way that like we know we
can do better the studios just have to
prioritize doing better it's
oh it's painful that like the amount of
people who work in video games who say
that too
we're all acutely aware of it and just
like oh god damn it i think yeah i think
that's why with with wayward when we
were like all right we're an indie game
we can do things in the way that we want
to we were like all right well our like
initial core team needs to have a writer
on it like georgia and also like um
like a like an audio person maze like
they were there from basically
day one or whatever um on the project
and kind of
influencing it and i think that has been
yeah just such uh
such a great way to work that it wasn't
like
we've built up this whole thing and then
right at the end we're bringing in a
writer or bringing in an audio person to
just like
make
add the audio can't even imagine how
those writers feel like i do have
friends who worked on projects like that
where you know they were hired late and
there was no writing and
yeah they were basically that direction
was basically hey make a character exist
in this level and just like
based on what context and also like they
have a limited amount of time and
they're not allowed to add any new cut
scenes like it's just
oh such a mess
yep yeah um jason to ask you the same
question
is there anything that you feel like
video games can really learn from other
mediums or vice versa outside of better
writing
yeah i mean yeah it's like i think um
[Music]
kind of like a confidence in like
personal storytelling and then i think
that's something that we're trying to do
with with wayward strand is to go like
we're telling stories that are personal
to us and meaningful to us and that is
like we believe that that will make it
engaging and interesting to other people
and um
you know um like for me a really big
influence on
um on on wayward strand in terms of
writing is like uh
like short stories like i i really love
uh like podcasts like the new yorker
fiction podcast or whatever where
writers are just like you know reading
their short stories or short stories by
other people and
that medium in that medium they're
totally unafraid to just be like this is
this is something that's like meaningful
to me it's set in the small town that i
grew up in and there are characters that
are based on the people in my life but
they just know that
that is going to resonate with other
people because like uh you know the
personal is universal or like whatever
that kind of um phrasing is and i think
in in games
maybe we're a little bit scared of doing
that like where there's still a bit of
that thing of like oh i don't know
whether that's going to
like
like my personal thing is going to make
this too niche or whatever yeah maybe
it's also that like we think that's not
what a video game is video games
actually
zombie steamers and maybe it's still
like trying to take the risks and step
outside of that more and more and get
more personal stories i have this uh
totally tweet
my tweet drafts faders and i'm like i
should keep that at some point it's uh i
just wish that people would stop saying
that video games or games events are
going to be bigger and better what if we
just did better
not everything needs to be bigger can
things just be better because like every
time that i get a game like i look up
all the time uh that website it's how
long to beat i think it's called and how
long things are and the minute
something's like six hours i'm like
thank you
it's gonna be more very good concise
video games but the marketing behind
video games is still very dubstep bigger
better
higher scale it's like going straight
for the end of the mcu rather than
giving the personal stories that they
gave beforehand i think you're right
that is
a thing that the industry feels afraid
of because it feels like it's not right
for video games but obviously everything
is that's the beauty of video games
anything can be anything but i
definitely i definitely agree with that
um i had a question i was gonna ask
based off of what you just said that
i've now completely forgotten i should
have written it down
um
you said something that i was like oh
that's a good thought but i've
completely forgotten what it was it
happens sometimes uh oh yeah it was
about short stories i was gonna say do
you have any recommendations short
stories always love hearing uh people's
favorites
yeah um uh one of the short story
collections that um that i feel like
really connects to to wayward strand for
me is um
stephanie vaughan's uh collection called
sweet talk and that's just like um
it's it's a
it's a collection where several of the
stories are kind of based on her
childhood growing up in like military
bases across like various parts of the
us and um
i like that's an example that always
pops into my mind because that's such a
specific
uh experience that like
very few people
in terms of like percentage of the
worldwide population would have shared
right like
growing up in these military bases and
stuff and and the feeling like these
kind of particular emotional things
about having to move school all the time
or whatever but like they feel so
like yeah i feel instantly connected to
the characters and and what's going on
um
yeah uh i don't know there's there's a
bunch i really like i'm stephen
millhouser um and like there's quite a
few short stories from him that i that i
really enjoy
because people tend to like
recommendations on this and i don't read
enough short stories i i give it a shout
all the time my favorite short story is
those who walk away from omalus
oh yeah which i absolutely love but i
just need to take more time to
read more short stories for sure well
the podcast that jason recommended of
the new yorker fiction podcast is it
rules because it's um they have writers
who are themselves writers who get
published in the new yorker but that
writer then goes back through the
archives and picks a short story by a
different writer
puts it out in full and then discusses
it with the fiction editor of the new
yorker about like what's good about it
that's such a cool idea it's basically
like a master class in writing like
every episode it's so good that's
awesome is that a weekly show or yeah oh
no monthly i think yeah sorry very cool
that's a very good shout out and yeah
that's the thing i also like to ask
people on the show if you have any
recommendations like what are the what
are what are some of your favorite
pieces of writing things that have
inspired either of you
well on the um on the short stories
thing as well if people listening to
this podcast are themselves writers or
interested in writing i've just finished
reading um a swim in a swim in a pond in
the rain is what i think it's called by
george saunders um and this is the best
book on writing
of all time i've never heard of it i
haven't read them all and i don't care
um what specifically did you feel was so
good about it so the premise is that
george saunders um teaches a course at
syracuse on the russian short story and
he's tried to condense that whole course
into book form so i think he says in the
book that typically in the course he
teaches 20 short stories but in the book
he teaches seven and he includes each of
the short stories in full and then like
a you know roughly 20 page essay after
each story talking like sort of
dissecting it looking at what we just
wanted
good
i've done
between
training and screenwriting and training
and playwriting i've done so many many
different like um creative writing
seminars or whatever
um and there are some stuff in this
there are some things in this book that
are so fundamental where even though i
really liked the places i trained and i
learned a lot there was a part of me
that was like so mad that this book
that's like 25 bucks taught me so much
is it about writing or is it about the
business stuff like obviously like you
know everyone talks about save the cat
and i do feel like save the cat is
useful but it's
useful for the stuff i didn't learn uh
when i was studying writing at
university but still not actually useful
to me as a writer very much it's more
about business
yeah it's not it's not about business
stuff it's about the writing stuff but i
think his focus in that book is like if
i was to try and distill down what i
took from it it's like um
just keep revising
forever like obviously at a certain
point you try and get something
published or whatever but just keep
going back and keep going back and he
just has this really great way of
drawing your attention to the level of
the sentence like so often we're trying
to think about like what's the arc of
this story or whatever and he he draws
your attention to that but via the
medium of like what's going on per
sentence and do you like it or not it's
kind of as simple as that he basically
is just like read the sentence is it
good does it please you does it make you
want to read the next sentence if not
there's work to be done
interesting
and then he sort of
has a lot of wisdom in talking about how
that relates to the broader structural
elements of the story so i mean it is a
good point that like when you say keep
revising and keep revising that
terrifies me because i'm a person who
revises my own paragraphs the minute
they're done it's like way too much like
it's a real problem but i guess like
when it's down to like making sure each
of your sentences has a point and leads
to the next sentence is something that
you can definitely get caught up in when
you're like oh i need to explain how
this saddle was made over 20 pages
reading tolkien as a kid like the
hobbit's the first book that i ever
remember finishing but i had trouble
with some of the lord of the rings
because i felt like some of the
descriptions were too much for me i was
very young at the time but i think even
that's a balance of like
a lot of people love those books
obviously um and i still do but it was a
very inaccessible because of the amount
of detail that was put into how one tree
looked
yeah that's the thing that's like you
ought to pick and choose what you like
to write and obviously you like to write
that oh
yeah dogs barking at something um
but i think it's also like the biggest
thing that i i tend to say to people who
are trying to get into um
writing it all is to just make sure that
you
enjoy what you're writing and you like
your characters i think that can be a
thing where i feel like if you don't
like your protagonist you're not going
to want to finish anything you write you
have to like them and care about them
and relate to them obviously
um
that was actually so that's just made me
think when you say like your characters
it really makes me think of wayward
strand because we have like we have
things about most of the characters that
are unlikable but at the end of the day
we were always like i know i wasn't
jason i'm sure you were as well just
like chasing this feeling of glee like
even if i know that
such and such a character is like
incredibly pompous like what's the most
pompous that he can be like
have like having fun
getting to inhabit that and being like
if i if i was this guy
how would i
be the most this guy
yeah that's true you can make you can
make it fun to inhabit the negative
characteristics that you don't like as
well and i mean that i think is a huge
writing flaw that video games fall into
all the time is making perfect
characters
like all the time it's just like
clearly hero fanfic
like
masturbatory like give me something that
that's wrong with them or something not
to like about them because that doesn't
make them unlikable it's that that makes
them relatable it makes them human it
makes them more digestible and yeah it
can be really fun to write as well for
sure
it's like how what miley cyrus said on
drag rates people want to relate to you
and no one relates to perfect it's true
yeah
and the great words of miley cyrus
my favorite writing teacher
do either of you have any other like
suggestions for
like go-to suggestions for people who
are watching or um listening at home who
want to get into writing
suggestions for people who want to get
into writing i think
um
beyond any specific suggestion just like
go as wide as you can and like if you
if you're in the bookstore or if you're
on the steam store or whatever and you
say something and your first response is
like uh not that
just try and push against that response
from time to time like follow your
pleasure as well and like engage with
the things that you love because that is
also instructive but um
just allow yourself to be surprised by
like i
as i mentioned before i'm playing disco
lizzie and i it's taken me so long to
play it because it just filled me with
such immense distaste like the look of
it and like i even played i think maybe
five minutes of it and the fact that he
just comes off as a real [ __ ]
initially and he's just like this
like
completely irresponsible misogynistic
whatever i was like i don't
i don't need this
i don't need to engage with this game to
experience misogyny i live on
um
but i decided to go back and i said no
people really talk about this game it's
time to like really find out what's here
and there's stuff there that's very very
worthwhile and i'm having a great time
um that's yeah that's the thing i don't
do that's a good tip is uh consume
things that aren't in your alley i do
not do that currently i go yeah not for
me i don't have enough time but i really
probably should and people too if
there's people in your life who you feel
uncomfortable relating to just like do
it anyway that's like why and yeah yeah
that is an interesting tip and yeah i
can definitely open you up to different
kinds of characters different kinds of
storytelling and
i definitely agree that makes you a
better writer for sure uh jason do you
have an answer your tip for people who
like yeah um yeah you mentioned the like
that the uh short story before and she
wrote a book on writing called like i
think it's called writing down the burns
um and i read that during wayward's
development that was like really really
useful
um like just a really good kind of like
thing where it like kind of prompts you
to do a whole bunch of writing and i
think that's something that like i think
i have that book back here i'm pretty
sure
yeah exactly yeah it's it yeah yeah it
is really good yeah um but yeah i think
i think that was the main thing that
popped to mind like um
yeah it's it's tricky because you can
always like there are so many of those
kind of books and you can get caught up
in
reading them instead of actually writing
but um i think that's why that that book
is really good is that it like is just
constantly prompting you to almost like
having a teacher now go away and write
something exactly yeah yeah yeah totally
it's very good hey uh
on the last episode tim was talking to
me about free writing which is not
something i've ever tried before yeah i
highly recommend just you just sit down
and just write for an hour and never
stop and never edit anything
as an exercise and i've done that twice
since and i was like wow this is really
good because it also
teaches me my specific patterns that i
wasn't aware of things that i repeatedly
write or like rely on or words i use too
often
um in a way that like i will
be fine to edit you know later if i'm
looking back at something but if i can
edit them in real time that seems much
more efficient i was like surprised at
how often i was using the same words and
like the same sentence structures and i
was like oh wow that was actually a
really really helpful exercise
and yeah i think like general advice is
just read a lot like everybody says it
but there are definitely people who
don't uh don't think that's important
and i would argue against that very
strongly
definitely helps
writing groups that's the other thing
that i would say
and it can be online it doesn't have to
be people that you know personally um if
you do have people you know personally
who are creative writers great but i
think that having
like writing is such a solitary thing
and there are
those of us who like have chosen it for
that reason but there are also those of
us who love it despite that reason um
and if you're someone like like getting
advice and getting input and getting
feedback from other writers can only
help your writing um so yeah finding
finding a writing group somewhere either
with your own community or online i have
one on discord
we just use discord and we share writing
with each other every week and it's like
very very helpful to read other people's
stuff all the time when it's in a drafty
state too
very easy to find i'm sure they have
facebook groups and stuff for that as
well
yeah it's it's so it's so good to see
other writers drafty stuff and be like
oh yeah everybody starts out with crap
and then you just improve from there and
like that's just the writing process
like that's yeah that's such a freeing
thing maybe except if you're stephen
king who apparently just
golden from the jump writing 10 books a
year jesus christ
that guy
[Laughter]
but when it comes to you know say
somebody's already very interested in
writing um
when it comes to actually trying to get
a job in the industry uh it sounds like
you both have pretty different
backgrounds as far as writing is
concerned what would you say to people
who you know have maybe already been to
university have already taken all the
writing classes are already doing all of
the stuff to make sure that they are
good writers how do they approach
getting work if you have any tips for
that
um it's hard
um
i think
uh this is gonna sound pragmatic and
maybe even a bit depressing but like
surrender to having a job that's not
writing at least for some part of it
like um
think think about what else you can do
that will bring you some amount of like
joy or interest in your life and the
thing is is that that thing that's your
day job which you initially consider to
be like a burden that's just there to
earn you money and that you want to one
day get rid of will actually if if
you're any good and if you
have like an attentiveness of the world
around you your day job can be such a
rich
source of like conditions to write about
information yeah exactly and it gives
you
well it gives you a broader life
experience and makes you a better writer
to have had experiences other than being
a writer which is an incredibly
unrelatable experience for most people
um
and then i also think i've been thinking
recently about like
how
there's kind of a real strategic art
which i don't think i'm a master of and
i think you sort of have to
think about day by day of
saying yes to everything initially
and then unlearning that skill at a
certain point um like saying yes to
everything in a way that's going to help
you meet people and expose yourself to
new ideas and whatever but then
realizing that you have to unlearn that
skill in order to narrow your focus on
any given opportunity or um experience
to like write something that's a bit
more substantial i've still not figured
that out anytime you know me either i
know i i've gotten far enough to know
that's what one must do
[Laughter]
yeah it's uh it's a start we're still
we're all still trying to figure it out
yeah
um jason how about you any advice for
people who are actually trying to get
worse as ready yeah
like yeah cause i reckon um you know for
people that have purely just writing
jobs in the industry um they are
like you know that kind of thing is a
little bit like you know a unicorn or
whatever uh like you know there are
those people but um so many of the
people that i know that do writing and
games also have other skills in games
and kind of like you know you might be a
producer and a writer or you might be a
programmer and a writer or you might be
you know something else in a writer and
kind of like
um
having uh like yeah that this is very
yeah a very practical thing but like
having more that you can offer as
opposed to like i'm just like i'm just
into writing and that's the only thing
that i like and i'm really good at it
and i don't do anything else
um
it's like
like i think it's just way more likely
if you've got a diversity of skills that
somebody's gonna go like oh yeah you
know we can bring this person on they
can be doing this when
when we need writing like they can be
doing writing they can do this when we
don't need writing because there's
often there are like significant
stretches on projects where the writing
is like done or like
you know whatever it is so kind of like
yeah thinking about in general in a in a
industry that's so competitive like
video games yeah um it's just making
yourself as employable as possible
right
making it so that you know for the
thousands of writers out there who are
unemployed who want jobs that there's
something on your resume that
automatically gives you the one up on
somebody else like when i was getting
into journalism i also took a
photography class so that i knew that i
could be the one to go take photos of
things uh so that that was an extra you
know benefit to an employer and then i
volunteered on community radio because i
was like
outlets these days like podcasts so i
started doing that just the amount of
things that you can stack up um to make
you stand out i think is great advice
like it it feels unfair that we have to
do that but when there are so many
people who really like writing and so
many uh and so few jobs um i definitely
think that that's really good advice
yeah make it so that you're the best
applicant uh outside of experience which
there's not as much you can do about
unfortunately yeah and and i think it
shows that you have like adaptability as
well like if you're kind of if you're
kind of somebody who's like oh i just
write and that's only thing that i do
and i haven't built up any other skills
it kind of feels a little bit like you
know i if you're coming onto this team
are you going to
kind of be a team player and do what
what needs to like kind of adapt to the
situations that we're in and that kind
of stuff like i think there's as well as
the
employability thing there's also
that's something that as somebody who's
hired people in the past i've kind of
thought about um
yeah it's it's just something um yeah to
consider as well i definitely think yeah
coming in with and how i can serve the
team as many ways as possible is a very
uh appealing thing for yeah something as
difficult as making a video game
yeah
the other thing that
something you were just saying a lot of
made me think is um that like another
thing that i would say to anyone who's
interested in writing is don't compete
um which is odd because you really
internalize a lesson especially if
you're in something like a creative
writing program and especially if you're
in one that's really vocational you get
force-fed this message of like these
people in the room they're your
competition and you have to be better
than them or whatever oh they're people
you can learn from
you can learn from them and also like if
you see an opportunity that comes up for
something
share it in your whatsapp with the other
people in your class um and like be like
if you see like journal submissions open
and you're like oh i'd like to
publish in this journal but i actually
know like olivia writes this stuff
that's perfect for this pitch send it to
her be like this sounds like your
writing um because when anyone gets
success there's like it builds success
in your community yeah like anyone who
whether it's you or whether it's someone
else
if you come up and you get opportunities
that gives you access to professional
networks and resources which your
community by extension then also have
access to yeah so you're you're taught
to think that like there's one there's
exactly one job and the best writer will
eventually get the one writing job but
in reality
like success in your community leads to
success in your community it's also
definitely a thing where um
well i still think like having that
mindset makes sense when it is a really
competitive industry to get a job in
that the people who act that way in
terms of like i'm gonna take this
opportunity even though clearly this
other person i worked with might be
better for it or like deserves it more
or could make more of an impact with it
those people actually don't survive i
think you get told that when you're in
school um that if you want to be number
one and you're acting like you're going
to be number one that that will lead you
to the top but generally it makes you a
really bad team player uh people won't
recommend you for things people won't
like working with you and i think game
development like
i've been in triple a for two years now
and i would say more of my job is about
working with the team than it is about
writing um exactly and sure i have to
write but that like hours of my day it's
much more about a team working together
to make cool [ __ ] and less about sitting
down on my computer and writing by
myself like that's
very little of my job in the grand
scheme of things it's a lot of meetings
and so even though i do think that we
get told to be competitive and cutthroat
and all that um
it's like this idea that you get maybe
from films again i do think school kind
of does that
because people don't actually succeed
they get weirded out very very fast
especially when the games community
specifically is quite small people know
each other totally yeah yeah you do you
do definitely benefit from um
like especially now i've been in the
industry 10 years total and the amount
of friends that i have who are like in
executive positions at different
companies who are all juniors at the
same time
you remember those people and you
recommend them for people and you're
getting each other work at that point
and like you know it just keeps growing
and growing and growing and growing and
growing and
there's no point burning bridges and
it's a common mistake that people make
when they're starting out
unfortunately
good advice across the board there i
think um is there anything else that you
guys wanted to touch on or add or say to
people who'll be playing uh wayward
strand this week
yeah
all right there you go georgia
ah i don't know um i think something
that we sometimes talk about with this
game is like um uh if you have the
opportunity to play it with someone
that's really nice especially in an
intergenerational way like we we've been
thinking that this game will probably
would probably be of interest to people
who and and we're finding that this is
true like even just in our own lives and
anecdotally it's of interest to people
who haven't played video games before or
think that they're not gamers or like
wouldn't play a video game um it's a
really perfect thing so if you're
someone who already likes video games
and there's someone in your life
especially like a parent or a
grandparent who's like oh video games
not my thing um play it with them uh
because i think it's you know
uh there was a point in time where
people thought that cinema was a gimmick
where we are now you know and i think
that video games are coming out or have
for the last sort of 10 years or so been
coming out of that phase of like but
there are still people who um you know
for very good reasons think that it's
all like blood and gore and violence and
and gimmicky sort of like
boy stuff
and uh yeah just just play it with
someone in your life who um who might be
interested to see what else a video game
could be a great tip
yeah
yeah um i think for me like just one of
the things that i'm really
excited to hear from people about is
just how
like how the game made them feel like
like how it how it how it all worked out
for them because
you know at the end of the day it's like
we've put a lot of work into it and a
lot of it's quite like polished and
stuff but it's still fundamentally this
like big experiment i feel and kind of
i'm just really curious to hear
like does the experiment work for people
like is it
is it um
you know
is it doing what we we think it's doing
where it is kind of opening up these
like really interesting new avenues of
storytelling um
and and yeah and and what what of all
the stuff that we have put into the game
are they finding and all that kind of
stuff are you gonna watch twitch streams
and youtube videos yeah yeah
definitely yeah yeah gonna be like glued
to them yeah i can't even imagine how
you're both feeling right now so
wild spot to be in
yeah
well congratulations and thank you so
much for chatting me today is there any
way that people can find you or anything
that you want to promote other than
wayward strand
there is nowhere anyone can find me
i do not have social media perhaps i
should i'm working at georgiasimmons.com
um but yeah this game is absolutely the
main thing i'm promoting right now how
about you guys yeah yeah i'm similar
i've got like a twitter that i post on
like
once every few months uh jason
underscore becca but like yeah just the
the game is the main thing yeah i guess
i i never actually asked where can
people find it what platforms is it on
oh yeah it'll be on um
like steam and also on like uh uh
playstation 5 playstation 4 switch
and xbox one and xbox series x and s
yeah sorry a lot of uh got them all
yeah yeah yeah we just decided to
to do them all
thank you guys so much for talking to me
today congratulations again thank you
for watching i'll see you next time
[Music]